[Musique]
les efforts devraient être cette fois
plus important qu'ils ne le sont
aujourd'hui si l'on veut rester en
dessous des 2 degrés de réchauffement
climatique on en est loin qu'en même
temps on en est loin et comme le dit
greta sundberg
la
france eux condamnés par sa propre
justice parce qu'elle n'a pas respecté
ses engagements carbone c'est ce que des
manifestants français était venu
rappeler à glasgow qui hier emmanuel
macron va venir à la coop pour
construire son image de dirigeant
responsable mais qu'en fait on est très
bien placé pour savoir qu'il n'en est
rien et que macro est au fond d'un des
plus mauvais élèves de la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique
qui piquent du nez lors du discours
d'ouverture de la coupe 26 l'image est
très commentée depuis hier
après 40 secondes de lutte un conseiller
s'approche et l'empêchent de faire une
comparaison casse gueule un peu comme
l'arrivée sur scène de charles venu
représenter la famille royale
ou la la mise en place d'un contrat
engagement jeunes à partir du mois de
mars prochain il va proposer aux moins
de 25 ans sans formation ni emploi
depuis plusieurs mois une aide de 500
euros en échange de 15 à 20 heures par
semaine de formation c'est bien parce
qu'il y à des emplois non pourvus que
nous assumons de ne pas verser une
allocation à tous jeunes qui seraient en
recherche d'emploi avec le risque fort
d'installer une prime à l'inactivité
c'est de l'assistanat et c'est une
mesure de clientélisme électoral à six
mois des élections bon voilà à emmanuel
macron il en campagne donc il a le
chéquier puis la rose et distribuer les
spéculoos eux à droite à gauche et on
est dans la démagogie on est à six mois
des élections
donc il faut vite faire une annonce de
plus comme il en fait une toutes les 48
heures essayez d'acheter méthodiquement
les clientèles une pas une c'est
extrêmement méprisant pour les français
et en l'occurrence mais présent pour les
jeunes ils essayent comme ça de les
acheter il fait campagne avec le
chéquier de la france tous les jours et
ça c'est insupportable
boris le gladiateur contre macron le
perturbateur avis de tempête dans la
presse anglaise très remonté contre la
france dans la crise des navires de
pêche emmanuel macron annonce une
reprise des négociations les discussions
ont repris sur la base des propositions
que j'ai faites les britanniques vont
revenir vers nous avec d'autres
propositions je veux bien les 48 heures
de plus mais alors il faut être
sacrément dur avec les britanniques ça
veut dire quoi vous savez les
britanniques ils ont toujours un
raisonnement très simple tout ce qui est
à eux et à eux tout ce qui est à nous se
négocient aux états unis la grande
majorité
des enfants qui ont sept ou huit ans
ce ne sont pas des blancs
la grande majorité ce sont des des
latinos des années soviétiques dans leur
pays on les surnomme les brûlures ils
ont mis le feu à leurs papiers
d'identité pour éviter l'expulsion
d'europe entre cerbère et le perthus
dans les pyrénées-orientales le nombre
de clandestins algériens qui tentent
d'entrer en france a explosé dans 20 ans
la géographie humaine de ce pays aura
complètement changé et vous parler de la
france ce n'est pas qu'à paris dans tout
le pays vous avez des mutations des
évolutions et aucune stratégie ne va
empêcher ces changements c'est le niveau
déjà là vous pensez aussi au parti
socialiste ça oui mais vous allez dire
ça me tue à quoi ça va pas oui le niveau
n'est pas là comédien ary abittan a été
mise en examen pour viols et placé sous
contrôle judiciaire cela fait suite à la
plainte déposée dimanche par une jeune
femme de 23 ans et vous voterez quand
même anne hidalgo mais attendez moi je
réponds pas non mais je veux dire vous
restez socialiste on verra